[Music]
this is the forbes ai50 list
50 of the most promising artificial
intelligence companies in the us
we've seen an absolute explosion of ai
opportunities
uh in the past decade and the year has
only accelerated that
this is the era of artificial
intelligence
horizontal ai is basically types of
artificial intelligence that can help
all sorts of different industries three
areas that are
particularly notable on this year's list
are first
the artificial intelligence workbench
these are the companies that artificial
intelligence engineers are building ai
in enterprises with these are companies
like dataku
datarobot domino data and data bricks
all of those are on the list this year
the next area that's horizontal ai
is computer vision this is the ability
for computers
to understand images in a way that's
useful to other humans
this is a continuous and very exciting
trend in ai you see companies like
viz.ai
which uses computer vision to detect
large vessel occlusions
a type of stroke very quickly and help
treat it
faster you see companies like amp
robotics
which are using artificial intelligence
to actually make recycling
faster easier more affordable and more
ubiquitous
the last of the horizontal trends
natural language processing
you can think about this as ways in
which computers
can understand language uh we've seen
this in a few ways we see it on the list
with duolingo
which is using artificial intelligence
to help people learn languages
better and faster we also see this with
whisper
which helps maybe uh your grandmother
maybe your parent who might have hearing
loss
better hear the people that they're with
my father actually has hearing loss he
really struggles to hear in loud places
restaurants and
you know that was when i was thinking
that a lot of the ai was i was using to
help
you know rank ads facilitate uh
consumerist toaster sales could could be
used to clean up audio
and help people hear their loved ones
more clearly
so whisper's actually really unique
which is fun in that we consider
ourselves a software business
we're not here to sell you hardware we
don't make money by trying to sell you
more stuff
we put the ai at the front and center of
our hearing aid we've designed it so
there's a hundred times more compute
than any other device on the market
it helps you hear more clearly and it
can change the audio in real time to
actually enhance the voices
we intend to stay laser focused on the
18 billion dollar a year and 300 million
person market of
just helping people hear their loved
ones again
the three vertical trends that uh i'm
super excited about
include artificial intelligence for
healthcare
artificial intelligence for logistics
and artificial intelligence
for communication for example in
healthcare we've seen
an absolute explosion in the number of
ai for drug discovery companies
we're thrilled to have verge genomics on
the list this year
at verge we're using machine learning
and human genomics to develop drugs for
patients with incurable diseases
with the mission of scaling this engine
to develop drugs
for a number of incurable diseases like
als alzheimer's disease and parkinson's
disease
so we have a large proprietary database
of patient brain tissues and we use that
to create models of what's causing the
disease and use
those to select genes or targets that we
believe are
the root cause of disease we're applying
machine learning
to really predict what drugs or what
targets might work in the lab and then
we're continuing to test them in the lab
rather than
starting with a guess and check method
in the lab
i'm not going to lie it's incredibly
challenging
it's been decades of failure but these
are diseases
that cannot be ignored they will be one
of the biggest burdens on the u.s
healthcare systems both economically
as well as from a health care burden
perspective so i think it's
unavoidable that we tackle these now
[Music]
in terms of logistics we've seen uh
continuing excitement
around autonomy and the ability to help
serve you
young customer by getting products to
you faster
cheaper more efficiently we're excited
to have
gaddick on the list this year
at gothic we are building an autonomous
delivery network for the middle mile
segment of the supply chain
so this segment is uh the segment
between long-haul trucking
on one end which is mostly highway
driving um and then
the slower moving b2c delivery robots on
the other
uh so those robots are traditionally
making deliveries to the uh customer's
doorstep
and karthik you know we are going after
this uh
middleman statement that has been hugely
underserved um
it is the unglamorous part of the whole
supply chain uh but for us this is
exciting because uh
it's a very constrained environment our
trucks are operating like busy bees
uh connecting these hub locations to the
smoke locations uh moving orders uh
day in and day out and uh from an
autonomy standpoint this is a very
structured and a very constrained use
case that allows us to commercialize the
technology and
you know uh bring the solution to the
market faster
as we've been in the covert era a lot of
us have been over zoom
a lot of us have been over video
conferencing we can connect with people
across the world almost as easily as we
can connect with people
down the block via zoom and that means
more and more people are speaking
more languages between each other a
company like lilt
which enables real-time translation
is an exciting business that we're
thrilled to also have on the list this
year
we got interested in starting to build
systems to where you could have the
efficiency and scalability of machines
but then the
quality assurance and ingenuity and
creativity of people
the core of the system is the neural
machine translation system
and the system gives suggestions to that
person while they translate so
what it looks like is you know i'm
reading english and i'm typing french
and the system is providing suggestions
to me while i type that's going to make
me more efficient
and the system has two unique
characteristics
that are not found in other neural
machine translation systems the first is
that it learns as it's used
so as people use it in this human in the
loop setting it's
it trains itself on the type of text
that they're translating
and the other thing that's unique is
that it's interactive meaning
that when you use it it'll make
predictions based on what you type
rather than just you know putting a
document in and then getting a document
out that's fully translated
cobit has forced all of us to digitize
more and to embrace technology more
that reality has actually propelled a
lot of things forward
the artificial intelligence revolution
is
potentially as big maybe bigger than the
internet revolution
and over the past 30 years we have seen
the internet just
absolutely transform our lives
artificial intelligence has the
potential to do the same
if not greater
you